[Música]
victoria y memoria para la líder
ambientalista berta cáceres este lunes
la corte suprema de honduras condenó el
ex presidente de la constructora de esa
que edificaba la presa hidroeléctrica
agua zarca en territorio del pueblo
lenca proyecto al que cáceres y su
comunidad se oponían el fallo fue
contundente en declarar culpable de
roberto di castillo por el delito de
asesinato ejecutado con alevosía
atribuyéndole en la condición de coautor
o coautor del asesinato la sentencia
concluye que cáceres fue asesinada por
liderar el movimiento de oposición a la
presa además el tribunal accedió a las
comunicaciones entre david castillo los
sicarios y otros directivos de la
empresa en que definían el crimen
estamos contentas y seguimos en
resistencia porque también tenemos la
certeza de que con david castillo no
termina esta lucha los compañeros de
lucha de cáceres quieren escalar en la
búsqueda de responsabilidades
la puerta a la autoría intelectual pero
que también hoy se le rinde homenaje a
la memoria de las tres una después
luchadora de este país que justamente
luchó contra la judía y por los derechos
de la población el asesinato de berta
cáceres conmocionó a su pueblo y al
mundo entero había sido galardonada en
2015 con el premio goldman la máxima
distinción a los defensores del medio
ambiente 7 personas ya están condenadas
por la autoría material del crimen la
pena impuesta a david castillo como
autor intelectual se conocerá el próximo
3 de agosto